mara and the Cubs haven't hunted
successfully since they're released into
the larger area but Mara is showing
interest in a water polo in the wild
lions normally eats every three to four
days when prey is readily available far
as desperate digging finally draws the
attention of a hungry Cubs but their
prey has long since given them the slip
Mara and Zyra watch hungrily as the
water makes its getaway it's a steep
learning curve for the Lions but to
survive in the wild they must learn to
hunt
Lions have the best chance of success by
hunting under the cover of darkness it's
been almost 10 days since the Lions ate
their hungry Mara's hunger lures her
back to the water bow clumsy with a lack
of energy
the Cubs help their mother digging
towards the source of the scent they
work as a team and rest in terms then
Letarte performs an intricate move that
will become this trademark among the
team
Linda calls it the corkscrew maneuver
after three hours of digging the Lions
finally extracted but killing us is a
risky task these tough little animals
can inflict a deadly blow with their
sharp tusks
they're exhausted the white lions have
teamed up and made their first kill it's
a defining moment for the project so far
but unseen challenges lie ahead